the friendly feud between Ryan Reynolds
and Hugh Jackman has given us endless
entertainment and it turns out we have
Scarlett Johansson to thank in a recent
interview with The Daily Beast you
opened up about how the feud got started
sent quotes I met him back on Wolverine
and I used to ream him because I was
very close friends with Scarlett
Johansson and Scarlett had just married
Ryan so when he came on set I was like
hey you better be on your best behavior
here pal because I'm watching and we
started ribbing each other that way and
then it all escalated with the Deadpool
thing and him calling me out and trying
to manipulate me through social media to
do what he wanted now recently Ryan was
trolling Hugh on Instagram after the
Aussie actor shared this suite post
celebrating his 24th anniversary with
the caption these 24 years have been the
best of my life and as far as I can see
we keep getting better I love you Deb's
with every fiber of my soul
happy Anniversary to witch Ryan
responded with this
hang in there Deb now when asked by The
Daily Beast if he was planning on
getting back at Ryan for that comment
the actor said quote I try to limit it
to five hours a day planning retribution
I found in the past that it just gets
unhealthy that's more than five hours of
obsessing over how to get Ryan Reynolds
but five hours is good and healthy and
keeps me strong and ready the two actors
started up their feud again this past
week after ad week gave a shadow to
ryan's company aviation gen for their
innovative advertising to which you
responded by tweeting this learn how
owner Ryan Reynolds does it really it's
perhaps the worst kept secret ever a
simple formula if you will two plus K
cups of Laughing Man in any given
24-hour period you're welcome so then
Ryan responded with this video while
drinking laughing man coffee well that's
just about the most insane thing I've
ever heard
okay so it seems like Hugh was maybe
right but nothing will ever be as funny
as when Ryan and Q seemingly put an end
to their feud last year when they made
commercials for each other's companies
Brian made a heartfelt promo for a
Laughing Man while Hugh didn't quite get
the memo
Ryan Reynolds is a complete and total
the June's pretty great thought I'll
have to try it someday
[Music]
sorry man I didn't think the truce was
actually real so what do you think about
ScarJo being the reason for why our
favorite online feud even exists let me
know in the comments below